could starger get more than just a
reboot but actually a Revival
and could we actually see a conclusion
to Stargate Universe an idea that I have
always dismissed but the evidence is
building
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV
movie channel
[Music]
I obviously talk about Stargate quite a
lot this is a Stargate Channel and you
know it's my favorite show it's the
sleeping giant of sci-fi and I 100 want
this show to return and I've been
following the story as closely as I
possibly can as we inch hopefully closer
towards that event the big day when the
Stargate series we'll get green lit or
movie could be a movie
but is it possible that instead of just
a reboot a continuation of the story
hopefully but with all new characters
and all new story and all new settings
could we actually get a Revival instead
where we would actually get as many of
the old actors back as possible continue
the story very much as if we never left
obviously with a 10-year Gap book you
know and could we actually see them
going to save Eli and the rest of the
crew from aboard the destiny could we
actually get a conclusion to Stargate
Universe now I get asked this a lot and
I know that's what you guys want or a
lot of you guys at the very least that
when we talk about this I will always
get comments saying where's SGU guess
give us a conclusion to Stargate
Universe give us a third season of
Stargate Universe now I always tell you
guys that's a very unlikely that that
was almost certainly not going to happen
simply because that's not what's been
done in the past when new shows like
this have been Rebooted but am I
actually thinking about how shows used
to be done instead of the trend more
recently because that Trend actually
does Point towards a Revival rather than
a soft reboot so rather than the Next
Generation we could just get a
continuation of something we're more
used to so let's have a look at a couple
of TV shows that actually have had
revivals recently Frasier is making a
comeback Arrested Development A couple
of years ago the X-Files a couple of
years ago Twin Peaks the list to be
honest goes on and on and on now the one
of the main reasons why I've always said
that there won't be this revival or a
continuation of SGU was well there's a
couple of reasons to be honest SGU
wasn't as massively popular as maybe sg1
now the people that love SGU adored it
they loved how it was a little bit
different from the other series they
loved that it was a little bit more
serious it took itself a little bit more
seriously that was a couple of reasons
why didn't like it so much I thought it
lost some of the joy that sg1 and SG
Atlantis had but it was still a good
show and it was getting better and that
was my frustration with it by the end of
the second season I was desperate to see
a third but it wasn't meant to be
so why do I actually believe a Revival
that might include SGU as possible well
there's a couple of rumors I've heard
that I've told you guys about the last
couple of months one being actually
Robert Carlisle's agent has been
approached about possibly returning for
some sort of Stargate franchise now I
haven't actually had anything since I
don't know if there's been any further
conversations I just know that he was
approached
um and it was a very informal if we were
would you consider it kind of approach
not a contractual thing or anything like
that so A Very informal varying maybe
maybe not sort of conversation we know
that Mark Fergus is in conversation with
Amazon and MGM about producing something
for the franchise we also know that
Amazon are leaning more towards doing a
movie first at the moment a nice holding
things up but we also know that Mark
Fergus in a recent marketing and
development meeting talked a lot about
Stargate Universe and was really really
Keen to talk about it we also know that
some point in the summer late spring
early summer last year Amazon did do a
survey and when they discussed the
results of that survey with Mark Fergus
SGU has brought up multiple times
so Amazon's research points towards
Target Universe Mark Fergus was very
excited to discuss Stargate Universe and
it would seem one of the main actors
from the series as though he'd
potentially been sounded out about a
return all of this points towards a
Revival I know another reason why I've
always thought the Revival was less
likely was because people won't
genuinely remember what happened in
Stargate Universe and it might be a
struggle to attract new viewers but the
thing is Target is a massive franchise
with a massive fan base and TV producers
seem to be a little bit braver than they
used to be when it comes to this sort of
project maybe it's because a lot of
these shows are on streaming services so
we can watch them whenever we want now
that executives are a little bit braver
they know that if they announce the
Stargate series people will go back and
watch the original series while they're
waiting for the new show to get made and
the people actually will remember what
happened in the show so creators can
still be very creative if that is the
case well and as I say they've done this
before it's relatively recent phenomenon
but it does seem to be something that is
sort of trendy in Hollywood and
Hollywood does like to go with things
like this it does like to go with things
that it considers to be safe and a
Revival might be more popular than a
reboot fans don't like reboots as much
and they definitely don't like hard
reboots so much it is a very risky
proposition to do a hard reboot for a
big franchise and I can only really
think of one occasion where it's been
particularly successful with Battlestar
Galactica other than that
I can't really think of any but a
Revival well that can be popular people
can feed into that Nostalgia they will
watch it even if it was just a short run
thing I'm hoping Stargate won't be but
look at for example Dexter the new
series of Dexter came out last year was
the year before I forget people watched
it but actually watching the series you
needed to remember the original series
you needed to remember how it ended I
actually had to go back and watch the
last couple of episodes because I
couldn't remember
but if you didn't remember you would
have no clue what the hell was going on
in that series now the second series of
Dexter new blood has actually been put
on pause but it was Showtime's biggest
series when it was released for the year
so they are keen and they are actually
looking at doing maybe two prequel
series that again will be directly
linked to the original one of them being
the Trinity Killer so they are relying
on the fact that people will remember
this show and will hopefully go back and
watch the original so that it will be
fresh in their minds if you actually
think about it it's kind of like killing
two birds with one stone you announce
one show and everybody runs off and
watches the other one so everyone's a
winner
so what do I really think is a Revival
more likely than a TNG style soft or
reasonably hard reboot well all of the
rumors I've heard over the last 18
months do suggest that Amazon are very
aware of what the fans are saying online
and what the fans actually want they're
very aware that this is a beloved
franchise we saw Roland Emerick six
months ago talking about how it seemed
that the TV audience was the audience
that MGM and Amazon cared about from an
executive's point of view a Revival that
returns lots of the characters that we
already love is a way safer bet than
introducing a whole sway of new
characters that we might not love
so from an executive point of view is it
also the safer bet
from our point of view we get to see the
characters we love
and at the end of the day it will feel
like Stargate still the risk of bringing
in totally new characters in a totally
new style to the show is that we might
lose that we might lose that sense of
what the show was this way at least we
can get that back I mean it is one of
the reasons why when they bring in a new
show that they try to bring in actors
from it you know so when SGA came in
they did try to bring actors through
like Rodney McKay from sg1 just so that
you know there's that little bit of
continuation and a little bit of you
know you feel at home watching the new
show so a Revival rather than a soft or
hybrid reboot for me makes loads and
loads of sense and a lot of the actors
like Michael Shanks Amanda tap in
um David Hewlett uh on and on and on Joe
Flanagan Etc would probably jump at the
chance of returning there's only really
Jason Momoa that I can think of that
probably has got better things to do so
it's possible it would be safer and the
fans would love it for me that's three
big reasons why a Revival makes more
sense than a continuation a Revival that
I will hand by my heart say I never
thought was even remotely possible but
we are getting hints and I will say the
hints and rumors that suggest this is
possibly a direction they're taking it
it also may be and this is just me
spitballing but it may also be another
reason why this has taken so damn long
because at continuation will be more
difficult it's more complicated you
don't just go out and hire new people
you have to actually talk to everybody
see who's available who's that you know
it's absolutely more complicated
Prospect
but first of all and I keep saying this
over and over again Amazon need to
decide what they're actually doing with
the Stargate franchise if they're doing
a movie great get on with it if they're
doing a series I think to be honest
better but get on with it you have
people lined up that are able to make
this you have people that are dying to
make this just let them but guys do you
agree with me get into the comments and
tell me exactly what you think is this a
safer bet is this more along the lines
of what we want um is a continuation and
a conclusion to SGU something that would
really excite you now I'm not saying
that SGU will be the main focus of this
show but it does seem that it could be
the way they start this new show it
could be how they lead into a new
storyline I think it would end up being
relatively small part of a much bigger
picture SGU is left on the ultimate
cliffhanger it is just floating out
there isn't it time to not only rescue
that crew but answer all of the big
questions that got asked in this
Stargate Universe series
I'd love to know exactly what you think
get in the comments if you are new to
the Channel please like subscribe hit
that Bell notification when you answer
that and if you want to really support
the channel consider hitting that join
button also go and check the description
there's loads of links to loads of other
Stargate and Sidetrack related stuff
as always please stay safe and I'll see
you next time
[Music]
thank you